so one of the things that you know those
of us who are huge fans of data-driven
cultures love to tell these stories and
champion them but we've also seen the
pitfalls that can arise when you become
too data-driven and so just for for
example if you in a search engine
pretty much every change you make is
going to go to an a/b test that is you
might get 1% of users who are going to
be exposed to the new algorithm or the
new font or the new color the new layout
and that's going to be compared to a
control group and because that data is
so strong and so powerful and so clear
and so black and white it's really easy
to pay a lot of attention to that but
then when you do something new or
different or something that might have a
long-term effect it's not necessarily
going to show up even in the right
direction in a short term test but
long-term tests are much more expensive
for if you're if you're doing an
advertiser experiment it might take be
disruptive for advertisers it might
change their prices or their their click
volume and so on so you don't do those
long-term experiments all the time and
you have to rely on some intuition and
judgment to know when is it worthwhile
to really put put put a change to
greater scrutiny and because we don't
always do it you can sometimes see an
organization push towards those things
which create short-term results but
might even be bad in the long term just
in his example when when Bing
what launched its rebrand the initial
response of the users in the short term
test was that they hated it they missed
their 10 blue links they didn't
understand this new more complex
interface search engines weren't
supposed to have richer content and and
more options to navigate the the search
so but it took weeks for the results to
come back where the users after a while
really liked it better so I can see that
as we go forward and firms become more
and more data-driven I think you also
expect to see firms sometimes just drive
off a cliff like sort of you know little
by little and then one day they wake up
you know the face the ads in the
Facebook feed they looked fine the users
didn't mind them they didn't my
they didn't mind them and then you know
one day they wake up and they've gone
somewhere else and that's something
that's a real challenge to balance